la lluvia caía con fuerza sobre miami
pero no impidió que cientos de
emigrantes cubanos y otras personas
contrarias al gobierno de díaz canel se
reunieran por tercer día consecutivo en
favor de las protestas en la isla
los últimos dos años una dictadura y
hace siete años
en realidad nunca 20 verano aparecido a
lo largo de la manifestación destacaba
el lema patria y vida contraparte del
famoso patria o muerte que adoptó la
revolución liderada por fidel castro-
pedidos también de ayuda al gobierno
estadounidense algunos incluso apuntan a
una intervención militar
vamos a pedirle sino una intervención lo
que sea por o algo que haga por el juego
una petición que también hicieron
decenas de cubanos desde costa rica
un grupo de personas se manifestó
también en la capital de españa allí
exigieron libertad de expresión y mayor
democracia en cuba durante el miércoles
del presidente español pedro sánchez
afirmó que en la isla no existe
democracia por la noche la comunidad de
madrid' iluminó su sede con la bandera
cubana detalle enorme y es un gesto
precioso de el cual los cubanos estamos
enormemente agradecidos y sólo podemos
decir gracias en buenos aires- la
embajada de cuba se vio rodeada de
manifestantes algunos en contra del
gobierno otros en favor de la soberanía
de la isla y el fin del bloqueo
estadounidense una muestra de la
disparidad de pasiones que levanta la
revolución cubana dentro y fuera del
continente